when the whole world is talking about
hump day I'm like it's [ __ ] mindset
day there's only a positive mindset
today so whatever that's gonna be
whether it's well I'm attacking the
barbell in the gym gonna attack my
emails if I'm feeling a bit a bit low
it's just just do your best today
because you need a positive mindset and
if we're waking up Monday morning
feeling sorry for ourselves we've got to
go to work what the [ __ ] are we doing
you are a living breathing example that
if you focus on integrity first you end
up with a competitive advantage the game
that no one is playing right now is the
honesty and integrity game only
motherfunking march on in the building
how you doing man make great it's about
time I'm doing very well
I'm very pleased to be here how you do
Chris I'm good one
this is such a long time coming the
Internet is waiting for this mmm you
feeling ready yeah I'm ready I'll be
literally looking for this all week
I've just had a cold shower just to wake
myself up make sure I'm primed and ready
at my best let's get stuck into it so
first things first you played rugby for
England sevens which was something that
I only stumbled upon when you post like
a throwback Thursday photo of a
fresh-faced ollie from a half a decade
ago um what are some of the ways that
playing high level sport at a young age
shaped who you are today it's a
brilliant question firstly address that
bit yeah I guess I guess anyone that
still followed me out of late over the
last two three four years will only see
me as like the fitness the fitness guy
but prior to that my my my life was the
be-all and end-all for me was was rugby
I had a couple of spells as a
professional rugby player but my most
successful one and in the I guess at the
highest level was winning the sevens and
that environment in itself is a very
high pressurized environment it's elite
sport and there's nowhere to hide the
game itself is very demanding both
mentally and physically you it's a bit
like Formula one in terms like a World
Series so you'll travel around you
travel around the world from place to
place and you'll be away for two to
three weeks at a time and then you'll be
back in the UK in training camps or six
six to eight weeks and during that time
the way the way things were set up is
that we all sort of lived all the
players add to commute
would live in a hotel in telling ttan in
in London so that environment you know
you're alongside the other players in I
guess a nice hotel but players digs for
some degree your environment where you
just eat sleeping and breathing
performance based sport using every
waking moment to try and just get a
little bit better understand the game a
little bit more it's a yes it's a
full-time it's a full-time job you're in
the gym one minute you know work a new
skills the other you might be doing some
conditioning at other times and then
when you are away from from home that's
you know quite tough as well because
there's a fair amount of travel to do is
a climate izing to the different time
zones there's then being able to lead up
to the to the competition and the
tournament over the weekend so that's a
new experience in itself and then you
playing two to three games across a
weekend or two or three days so there's
a fair amount of getting yourself up for
a game bring yourself back down having
to recover bring yourself back up then
you know spent you know sleeping
getting back up for date day to and
anyone that's played rugby or know
there's a farm at an ox and when you're
playing sevens which is at high speed
it's almost you're taking the guys that
are like just the best best athletes you
know that they're big strong quick big
engines wrote very robust very resilient
and you're putting them on a field where
there's acres of space and just sound
right like game on
it's amazing I think rugby pitch is a
pretty big bit of turf and then you you
only have seven people per side to fill
that with there's just bags and bags and
bags of room I think yeah I think a lot
of people that obviously follow me now
with fitness the best thing I can liken
it to is like a CrossFit make on that
sort of four to seven four to six
minutes I mean because games are seven
minutes a half with it like I think it's
two or three minutes a half time maybe
even less than that so it's seven
minutes of nowhere to hide yeah
intensity there's this this sprit like
acceleration/deceleration a little bit
of maybe catching your breath during
peak times as has impact there's there's
tackles there's rocks there's having to
catch this skill element so it's it's a
bit like CrossFit in a sense you know
the techno when you mean you blend the
technical lifts it requires you to link
the whole kinetic chain and then there's
a bit where it's like on a
on assault bike where you need to rip it
and they need to get ready to do
pull-ups and this for strength element
is it's a bit like that it's very very
demanding also not far off three rounds
of a UFC bout yeah I mean honestly May
when people I guess when people see some
of the conditioning pieces or what I
have done in the past I'm not really
like that
so much anymore and I've got a bit older
and maybe a bit wiser and other
responsibilities but when people Steve
Doocy some of the workouts and stuff
that I've done it's very much been
influenced by my time during sevens you
know and we talk about that environment
I went and did a training camp pre World
Cup in Russia sevens woke up and Russia
and teens up in the Alps so that was
training altitude you know sevens
training altitude up in the mountains
it's just a different beast so yeah it's
it's an incredible sport but yeah at
that level and they're very very highly
elite athletes who is the biggest freak
savage that you saw during your time in
sevens on the world circuit or who do
you think some of the most impressive
athletes that you saw during your time
playing and why
I think was a for me it was a
realization that I've always been quite
fast they're coming from athletics
background and always been a sprinter
sort of county level 100 meters 200
meters that sort of stuff but when you
get on a rugby field with sevens
and I'll use someone like Dan Norton
who's England's in the sevens legend
that guy so I was I was a hybrid I was a
winger and uh nan da play hooker so I
was like this utility pound I guess
that's the story of my my career in
rugby throughout just this jack of all
trades master of none I guess it leads
into my fitness career but when you want
to put your on that on the pitch with
someone like that and Carla Niles these
these are top level sprinters they could
hold their own to some degree with you
know honor on a track and they just run
away they'll run away from you if you
don't make if you don't think of
positioning right making it young making
a tackle it was a baptism of fire
training alongside Dan like particularly
wise you know in train training games
he's a he's a starting winger I'm
marking him in defense if I didn't get
my tackle right on him I was used to
coming from a 15s background or just
playing the seventh circuit I could turn
and chase the guy down and make a tackle
from a honed if someone like noughts got
around you you just eaten dust there's
no point in chasing yeah well you just
let you just learn how to defend guys
with with footwork with speed so that's
somewhat you know it's someone that was
in my position that I'd train with day
to day of course like he's one of the
fastest cars in the circuit there are
others are up there and then I had my
debut in Dubai and the two teams in our
group was to South Africa in Samoa and
there's a third teams were Portugal but
I was playing again hooker and winged I
remember coming onto the field and scrum
engine down at hooker so you know
there's three versus three and it's
basically like it you know it's a it's a
man test these the scrums aren't very
long it's just basically who can who can
have that biggest initial impact get the
ball out and we and we crack on and when
you're packing down at five foot nine I
was about 86 kilos at the time against
three big Samoans and South Africans
although I wake up I wake up day to mate
and I my neck had never felt anything
like - trying to just twist and turn my
head I've never
anything like it they really oh really
it's a complete test of speed
physicality endurance strength power and
its really shaped Who I you know my view
on fitness and what why I why I've
become this sort of like generous in
terms of fitness and I guess why my
style of training fits very work well
within the CrossFit functional fitness
space because it's a true test across
all different modalities how much has
your rugby sevens background influenced
how quick you can run after your toddler
son no funnily enough my wife always
beats me to run off just a mother's
instinct yeah I think my rugby sevens
background is influenced a lot like a
lot in my life
I think I think maybe not so much
parenting but definitely but definitely
like I said the word fitness and the way
I just view day-to-day putting myself in
the firing line very high-pressure
environment looking for challenges and
knowing that
yeah put myself in environment where you
make one mistake and that could cost
cost you the game yeah you miss a tackle
on the seventh field and that guys is
getting through and unless you're
sweeper inherently you're not your scrum
off is is going to make that tackle it
falls on you and so that is a lot of
faith in your own ability
I think so I like it said the
environment right now as well with with
this covered thing and and people saying
and how you feeling about it and I've
just got so much faith in my own ability
more so in my work ethic than my ability
because I think a lot of the and again
I'm I'm a doing myself a disservice when
I talk about the sort stuff but I never
had ooh BRR amounts of talent you know
as never the tallest the biggest the
strongest the quickest I had a I
developed a work ethic from a very young
age instilled on me by my by my father I
at times I took some of my talents for
granted and that then led to some
shortfalls when I got injured in in my
initial sentence a rugby player so I got
injured and I couldn't play for 12 to 18
months and and that taught me a few life
lessons as well about not taking things
for granted I've alluded to this in the
past that growing up my my all I wanted
to be was a professional athlete and
once I got that you know you saw get to
the top of the mountain you know I was
nowhere near the top of the mountain but
I got that professional tag line or so I
so I thought I then started taking
things for granted didn't do the work
Tim put in the extra hours think above
and beyond all these things that now I
do to the enth degree got injured
realize that you know I wasn't I wasn't
invaluable or not I could you know they
just pushed me to the side and the next
minute I was waking up in University
halls as a as a fresher while actually
travelling in China and and then and
then I'm a fresher and I'm you know my
life was completely changed and turned
upside down from being professional
athlete and that that's what me a few
life lessons how much do you think the
lessons that your dad taught you or to
do with his heritage because you're is
it subcontinent old is it Indian what is
it mmm massively massively that I
actually been thinking more of this I'm
gonna maybe go a little bit of tangent
with the whole black lives matter thing
because I've done a lot of thinking
about my own personal experiences
growing up as a person of color now a
lot of people even today someone said to
me Jesus you're tanned like where've you
been
now a lot of people now might just see
me as a as a as a as a you know
caucasian has subscribed pretty extreme
needs a bit of colour and mu yeah but
but when I was younger I was always
subject to racism and
and not not massively but again it's a
bit of a tangent but I've done a lot of
thinking about my culture growing up and
how my my relationship was with my dad
and yeah that's definitely shaped Who I
am today though I think there was a work
I think installing my dad was a was a
surgeon I think this was passed down to
him from his father the legend goes in
my family that my granddad I never got
to meet him he actually decided what my
uncles and aunties would go and study so
my dad obviously went went into medicine
my eldest uncle he became a priest and
coincidentally since then he's he became
an alcoholic and he died he passed that
passed away of being an alcoholic I
don't know whether that's linked to
upbringing and maybe he took the career
in which he went into war so another
certain other issues but my dad saw the
family very high achievers and I don't
mean that just purely monetary I mean
that by you know they push their needle
hard very successful in in business and
my dad was very successful in his in
medicine and I think being the eldest
son there was a lot of pressure on my
shoulders I studied psychology chemistry
biology at a-level because I you know I
thought I had to go and be you know
become a doctor soon realized that that
wasn't for me when I got my grades back
that just that lonely what would be
seems a little bit safer option than
this doctoring [ __ ] sounds a bit hard
yeah but there was definite there's
definitely sat yeah and then that
imposed on me I think some families like
I said I never had it I didn't have a
tough upbringing I was very fortunate my
I never wanted for anything but that my
dad was very disciplinarian he was very
authoritative it was those a you know
there were times when myself and him
very much clash particular got into my
teenage years on you know got a little
bit bigger a little bit you know a
little bit more cocksure of myself we
really didn't really did clash and I
think the communication between the two
of us was poor for a number of years
because we just didn't see eye to eye on
things but now I'm a bit older a bit bit
wiser and I can look back at what he did
installing me I'm incredibly grateful
for and I took my first job at 14 years
old and they were all things that you
know I think we're sitting still enemy
from for my father
one of the things that you mentioned was
about having faith in your future self I
got a buddy a real character guy called
Andrew Tate who is a son of a chess
grandmaster world champion kickboxer
multimillionaire
living in Romania driving fat he's like
a real-life genius James Bond meets Dan
Bilzerian he's got a brother he's got a
brother right Tristan yeah I know he put
this thing up some of his stuff he posts
rap lyrics rap lyrics are less so for me
but some of the stuff that he puts up
has absolute pearls of wisdom in and he
did this one about um I don't care about
spending money I don't care about
deciding to buy this car or those shoes
or this house or that dog or take this
girl out or do any of that stuff I have
faith that future Andrew will make it
work that if I decide to spend my money
now the Andrew in the future will make
it work no matter what happens and that
really stuck with me this idea of having
so much trust in your future self that
you have expanded your domain of
decision-making in the present to
account for what you know is a
capability in the future and I think one
of the problems that a lot of people
have is that when they consistently make
promises to themselves that they break
I'm going to stop drinking this year I'm
going to stop cheating on my boyfriend
this year I'm going to lose weight do
this do that every time that you make
one of those promises to yourself and
you break it your brain keeps no your
mind knows that you said imagine that
you're friends with so on and this
friend keeps on turning up late or
doesn't arrive at dinner after a little
while he'd be like I'm not inviting you
out for dinner anymore because I don't
trust that you're even gonna show up you
have to see yourself as that friend
right you are a friend to yourself in a
very real way we talk to ourselves our
inner monologue occurs as if we're
talking to somebody else what did he do
that for that was a stupid thing to do
you know and I think that what you
appear to have tried to cultivate here
is overtime expanding that domain of
competence so that you have faith that
you will be able to do those things in
future right future ollie we'll get it
sorted yeah completely I think it's
having faith in whatever your talent is
wherever your passion is it's really
doubling down on that and then if you
can apply some work ethic with that and
be confident in it for me yeah I've been
thinking about it a lot recently as well
for me I just want to I work as hard as
I can to try and get a seat at the table
in whatever industry or whatever table
that might be at and I notice a bit of
like I've been lounge you there but if I
can get a seat at the table then I've
got a chance to eat and I've got a
chance to listen to the to the people
that are at that table that know more
than me and whatever particular field
that may be and I get a chance to
network with those people and
communicate with them and whether it's
in fishes whether it's in business
whether it's in a you know listening to
you know the chance to come on this
podcast you know the guests that have
come before me you know are people you
know that I'm happy to say they use
these some incredible people that
released books that you know huge
followings but I managed what I've done
I've managed to get a seat at the table
in the modern Western podcast John I
mean it's the same with it's the same
when I I get an opportunity to to sit
and and just listen or take in
information from guys that are in the
financial world or understand a little
bit more about business understanding a
little bit more about marketing and
understand more about fitness than me so
if I can continue to show that people
can trust in me you mentioned that piece
there about you know all the people that
are flaky you know you won't ever get
that from me I will always show up and
you can always trust in me to be there
for and do what I say I'm going to do
and but I think because of that
different people then buy into who I am
and what I'm about and like I said that
gives me a seat at the table if I can
get a seat at the table I get a chance I
get a chance to eat and I get a chance
to listen and I get a chance to network
and I get a chance to grow I get a
chance to be a little bit uncomfortable
with my with my company and then you
know I level up you you've got to catch
up with them right it's that it's
interesting to hear from someone who
purposefully puts themselves into
situations where they're out of their
depth and I think one of the real
reasons why your audience resonates with
you online I know that I do as well is
that
I hope that it's one of the reasons that
the audience listening to this podcast
enjoyed this as well the I try not to
mince my words I make a point of never
ever cutting an episode unless there's
something libelous or a connection drop
out I don't I don't ever settle with it
so I forget a word I say the wrong thing
there's this episode of Daniel Shmack
Tim burger where was 20 seconds of pure
silence and I was like not that's
staying in because he meant it to be in
there I want the audience to have faith
that what they get is what happened and
I think the same thing for you with the
people that you work with it's like if
you want to put your faith in me if you
ask me to turn up as a husband a father
a business owner a coach and athlete and
ambassador whatever it might be I'm
gonna do it you want me to do a thing
and I'm gonna do it and given kind of
the last few years of the Instagram
influencer world and obviously I've
contributed to this terribly with the go
from zero to hero love island reality TV
a transformation that happens where
people are chosen for not their talent
simply their presence the you can pick
someone up like a Tommy Fury he was
great on love island and became like
this world national star and no one
cared about how good he was at the thing
he dedicated his life to what does that
teach us it teaches us that Fame doesn't
actually be to be need to be being
famous for anything fame is about
notoriety by any means and I really
think that there is a counterculture now
that people are resonating with and it's
virtuous integrity driven content that
is meaningful and an honest and truthful
and as you see Instagram testing out
removing the light count from underneath
posts and rolling that out across the
world that is going to further increase
people's likelihood of posting things
which to the Creator makes sense to the
Creator feels like it resonates they
might care about how many comments they
get that a meaningful as opposed to the
light counter that underneath the post
and what this kind of all loops around
to is that you are a living breathing
example that if you focus on integrity
first
you end up with a competitive advantage
going for the lowest common denominator
and just trying to pick the easiest
fruit that you can works but everyone
can do that the game that no one is
playing right now is the honesty and
integrity game yeah because I think it
within time people see through all of
that stuff and if there's no substance
beyond it and then that's where the you
know there's nothing there's nothing
thence then to follow and I think with
it we think that whole thing I don't
need I don't want or desire at all to
have tens of thousands hundred thousands
millions of followers well I would I
really what really you know gives me
enjoyment fulfillment is the connections
so I'd rather have a much smaller
following that I can actually connect
with and going back to the analogy like
if I can get a seat at the table with X
Y and Zed and these people that are
higher level and I can take from it and
then I can like give to my my people and
and give them like that tangible
connection to it because not everyone's
going to get these sort of chances in
life for one reason or the other so if I
can leverage my talents my work ethic my
drive my you know ability maybe just a
talk you know talk a good game until I
get to gets that table and it's going to
help yeah yeah exactly and then go and
help the people that that have supported
me on the way then I'm doing my job
it's like yeah for me it's just about
connections and you soon see that people
that people follow my social media you
know my stories in particular the way at
the way I had their way around my
stories it's going to be some value in
there every now and again fluttered in
there's a bit of my son there's a bit of
my wife it's a bit of just me sharing
what the amazing community that we've
built that engaged in our fitness
there's a lot of money if there's a lot
of food but then there's a lot of
there's a lot of food and it's the same
it's the same show every day right and I
gent like I've alluded to this in the
past it's definitely not an exciting
thing to follow when I post a picture of
a salad but it's the same people that
will actually show up and watch my
picture the salad that I actually care
about following me
so I mean cuz they're like I'm holding
myself accountable to things that I do
every day by posting this salad I know
you find it boring but thanks for
actually showing up and still following
support and like this is this is my
journalist my accountability so when
you're still following it you still
watch it yeah and the thing is as well
when you decide to do that if you decide
to consistently give to the audience
they will give back to you and this
doesn't just happen for content creators
it's all well and good me and you as two
people that have two
produce or choose to produce content
every day but this goes for everyone
that's listening your relationship with
your mother or your children you know
your parents or your children you want
to have a reciprocal relationship you
want them to have faith that you're
going to do the things that you say that
you're going to do and when it comes
from a business entrepreneurial sense I
wish I wish that I'd realize 10 years
ago that going wide and shallow is
nowhere near as effective as going
narrow and deep I would much sooner be
the best podcaster in Europe within the
wisdom space then try to be [ __ ]
model DJ could promote a reality TV info
you know I mean I don't I don't need all
that I need the thing that I love and I
want to become great at it and you know
thankfully what you have or at least it
appears to I'm going to get onto this
now as a lifestyle kind of aligns in one
way or another but one of the things
that I find most fascinating about
yourself is that you are athlete
businessman coach Family Guy as in dad
and husband and brother and son and all
of this stuff you appear to have quite a
hectic like classic sub-continental
family thing like tons of extended
family there's all it's always like
every other weeks of someone's birthday
or a barbecue or something like that
what are the things that you do to
ensure that you keep all of this aligned
everyone that watches your stuff getting
up with shark mentality 4:30 in the
morning like how do you piece this
routine together good question
and then yeah sometimes I don't really
know sometimes I feel as though I fall
short on some of those elements you know
if we look at you know who identify us
now and you've listed offer a fair
amount there I liken it again to playing
spinning plates or turning turning a
dimmer switch up at certain times there
are certain times a day in which I need
to I really need to turn the dimmer
switch up on being a coach because I'm
in front of people and I'm coaching it
was my time to Train so that's why I
just need to block out my time and just
get my you know get the work done that I
need to get done when I'm back home I do
find it very difficult to try and switch
off and be present around my family
that's something I I really need to
still develop
you know just because I am a father a
businessman an athlete and all these
things it doesn't mean I'm very good at
all of them don't get me wrong this this
time which I really do get it wrong and
then I have good people around me that
will tell me and that we have an honest
conversation I'm pretty good and pretty
self-aware as well so I'll do a lot of
self-reflection on how on how I think
I'll performed a certain day or a
certain week on certain tasks and and
then I'm able to maybe adjusting and
remodel myself for the week to come but
I think you mentioned about you know
shot Mondays and that sort of thing for
me though those little bits are just
it's just the narrative I think it when
it comes when we link at this to mindset
when I was a when I was a rugby player
or just a personal trainer there was
never any anxieties about what I was
doing day to day because I was just so
in I just enjoyed every moment of waking
up and being a professional athlete and
said of course I decided that I was
going to walk away from that same with
personal training I've never really
viewed it as work I was just energy in
which I'd created my first my first gym
and just coaching people it was really
it was really sort of flow state when
I'm on the gym floor I find it really
easy when ice transitions a business
owner and the other bits and pieces
which you have to sort of learn about
you know like being a being a husband
and being a father and those sort of
things then anxieties and stresses in
and more weigh on you and there didn't
you yeah so so for me I'd never on a
Sunday night like most people used to
get that artist Monday morning tomorrow
when it when everyone else playing rugby
it's like I cannot wait for it to be to
be to be Monday I never used to get that
that hump day thing on a Wednesday
because I just didn't have that slump
and you get these people that are
employees that work on i-25 and they're
just living for the weekend that was
never me but when it moved into being a
more owner operator of a gym business
and all these other things that I then
had to try and teach myself or learn
about I started to get these these these
feelings of like oh [ __ ] I've got to get
back I've got to do you have got answer
emails I've got these things that didn't
really come very naturally to me I
didn't really enjoy so just to change
the narrative in my head like if you if
you wake up and the first thing you
think yourself is I'm gonna be a [ __ ]
shark today you know you did whenever a
negative thought creeps into your head
it's like hang on no no no that sharks
don't thing like that you know I know
it's it it's a child it may be
childish way to put a spin on things a
mindset day like Wednesday whenever when
the whole world is talking about hump
day I'm like it's [ __ ] mindset day
and now is there's only a positive
mindset today so whatever that's going
to be whether it's well I'm stacking the
barbell in the gym whether it's whether
I'm going to attack my emails whether
it's how you know if I'm feeling a bit a
bit low it's just just do your best
today because you need a positive
mindset and then I find myself getting
through the week and I'm not just the
weekend chilled achieves so I said I put
out the other day you know we live out
the narrative each day that we sort of
tell ourselves and if we're waking up
Monday morning feeling sorry for
ourselves we've got to go to work like
what the [ __ ] are we doing you know
check changed the story or just checked
out change tip your life upside down and
leave your job because that's no way to
exist and I think particularly people
have found during Kovac because there's
a lot of self-reflection at least they
should of is that people are just
existing and enduring life and letting
life letting life employ them they're
employed by their employer and they're
employed by life and they live nothing
on their terms
so mindset they shot Monday that's my
way you know you're a big man on morning
routines and I'm sure yours is fairly if
a lot more polished than mine but it's
my way of setting my intention for the
day this is how I'm going about it I'm
on the front foot I you know we say we
do you talk about you know when in the
morning win the day I'm winning my first
thought and on Sunday night when I'm
when I'm preparing myself to go to bed
I'm like it's [ __ ] shot man let's get
it yeah exactly there are two equivalent
the people listening to this podcast may
be familiar with James Altucher past
modern wisdom guests has a fantastic
blog post called not useful and not
useful is an ongoing mental tool he uses
the same as your shark Mondays
so whenever a thought creeps into his
mind that he doesn't want in there
something negative negative self-talk a
concern and anxiety a fear he labels it
realizes that he's thinking this thing
labels it is not useful is it useful not
useful
then allows it to go look what are you
thinking a thing if it's not useful to
you it genuinely isn't do you want to be
worrying about whether or not that tax
bill that's due in a month and a half's
time is actually going to get done are
you going to worry about whether or not
your boss is going to be not useful if
it happens you'll deal with it when it
happens there's this quote that I
tweeted yesterday from Shane parish as
well guy behind Farnam Street it's not
who you think you are or who you want to
be you are what you do consistently it's
not enough to say the right words or
even think the right things you have to
act on them hmm yeah it's pretty out of
power it's brilliant I mean everything
you just said it I think when it comes
to these things I've been an early
adopter of all of these things not
unknowingly you know the things with the
mindset the things with you know fitness
orientated stuff you go I'm going back
sort of 10 years
behavioral science suffers now I'm not
saying it's caught up I'm not saying I
was ahead of you ollie Marcin is a
transient here I guess what I'm saying
is by default I've because I've got an
awareness of these of these things or
how I wanted to try and thrive in my
life and the things I needed to do to
try and get there I started to implement
and I started to put things in place and
then they naturally I guess then get led
to it a bit more success some things
didn't work there's been times where
I've really burnt myself out and got it
completely wrong because I just didn't
know what I was doing and then as things
become more more evident more research
and more more work gets put in to the
way people behave and what how they
should behave then I'm not a [ __ ] like
that's something I've kind of been doing
I've not been doing it quite right but
I've done my I'm my version of it yeah
one of the things what one of the things
you mentioned was that you iterate on
self-reflection and what you can presume
is it doesn't really matter whether
you're a bookworm or not whether you're
consuming hours of podcasts every week
in little audible subscription max style
and all this stuff air pods never leave
your ears all this [ __ ] it doesn't
really matter about that because you've
identified that over the last decade
you've allowed an evolution of ideas and
a survival of the fittest in terms of
mindset approaches ways of dealing with
business
small failures haven't knocked you off
you've allowed them to be what they are
okay that's a lesson I'll try not to
repeat it and the good things that
you've done you've allowed to stay with
you and what that's allowed you to do
over time is to iterate this evolution
of Ali's mind which now has inevitably
come upon some of the stuff that
research says because if what you had
found disagreed with the research
there's more research to be done because
you're apparently some well of unique
information insight of course that's
going to be the case if you exist in the
world for long enough you would be able
to stumble across pretty much all of the
insights of science you would just need
to look at things with sufficient
dexterity so that you will actually end
up real well this is how motivation
works or this is why you've got a ego
depletion and willpower is actually
finite but perhaps if I have an app
willpower can come back like you don't
need to run tons and tons of focus
groups you just need enough time and
enough attention to actually work out
what's going on and that's why as you
say over time you've allowed yourself as
a coach businessman dad all this sort of
stuff to these emergent realizations
have occurred and now I think you've
started to layer on top some more
consumption of books of podcasts of
audiobooks of coaching the Coaches
Association you're a part of Knight
master trainer all these people you're
exposing yourself to and that's when
you're going to really start to level up
right yeah I think just on the research
thing research is always there just to
fit someone's bias and also it only
becomes relevant when there's luck at a
problem they need to fix I didn't want
to be I didn't want it I never wanted to
be a part of that cohort of the problem
they need to fix so I wanted to try and
get I guess I by trying to be ahead of
it and trying to adopt all these
principles and things that there was
whispering you know this might work but
it might be a complete waste of time
there might be no science and stuff
behind it well let's just give it a go
why not on my own experiment I've got
nothing to lose other than just a bit of
learning and the learning thing I think
is really important here like most
people struggle with the the notion of
putting in more effort to things whether
it's their fitness whether it's
relationships whether it's the the way
they view their nutrition what they do
with their nighttime routine or going to
bed or all those kind of things like
effort is where people actually lack but
effort is where the body just learns
same with the people that you're trying
to teach a press-up to three years off
they do their first press up like why
can't you just accept the fact that just
think a little bit more about what we're
trying to do here and we're trying to
connect the full body to move is one
pick like one piece that rather than
just bang out the reps as fast as they
can and think that moving through
something faster is gonna be better
surely that's that that's going to be
better for me not take your time slow
down think about what you're trying to
achieve and your body will learn and
therefore you can move on so that you
get the prerequisites to move with your
press up on to the next thing I mean
amazing press up as an example very
basic of course but the point being
through more effort becomes more
learning and that's where then you get
to a level where the learning might need
to change it might not be I can't just
keep experiment on myself I think to
start and read read put this into
context read the latest literature
that's the advantage of you having a
brother right that you can just just
start experimenting on him see if this
works
just make can you grow a mustache for me
please see if you live to go up put this
cap on backwards see if you let's go
slightly short short slightly longer
socks exactly that way that's exactly
what Charlie do you exist for he's my
little lab rat sorry Chad yeah I love
that man and pushing yourself into those
areas of discomfort is something that
for some people if you're more Type B is
is going to be a challenge whereas
relinquishing that if you're type-a is
going to be a challenge so let's talk
about some of the times where you've
perhaps either pushed yourself too hard
or how you are how you've learned over
time when you are pushing too hard and
some of the mindset approaches that
you're using to give yourself that
breathing room to say okay Ollie like 60
hours of work this week is enough for
this many miles this many calories you
know how have you allowed yourself to
let go of that tether yeah so let's
address the I guess the sort of
learnings I've had a had along the way
like I said when I when I was in the
rugby environment when things a lot of
things were done for you like your your
output was monitored you'd wear GPS
trackers your your program was was
prescribed for you
your nutrition was looked after it's a
very safe environment you can't really
get things very wrong unless there's a
an injury or something that is just a
freak accident
when I moved into being a personal
trainer and running my own business I
was I've never had been employed by
anyone in the fitness industry so I
worked myself from the get-go
there's no I'm really teaching you about
how many hours of good delivery you can
do how that then fits into your own
training how that fits into your sleep
at the time when I first started I was I
was I used to Train coach the party and
go out at weekends all that kind of
stuff so you get it wrong right and you
drop the ball somewhere and then when I
did finish playing rugby and I moved
into owning my own gym I put all of my
that work ethic that drive that passion
that tenacity into trying to run a
business and and yeah I've burnt myself
out I just got to complete completely
wrong
I got it spiraled out into it into a
stage where if I wasn't actively sat
down working on my business
quote-unquote my only other outlet that
I knew about was training or some sort
of physical pursuit or endeavor so I
found myself going on ridiculously long
runs
swimming doing endurance stuff because I
could feel the time that meant I didn't
need to sit down because if I sat down I
had to be doing work of some sort were
you with your missus at this point yeah
and so I was with my missus my missus
you know with laws she was she was
working as a air hostess at a time for
BA which again is a horrific job I feel
for anyone that works as a as an air
hostess she's done it because she wanted
to see the world she went to some
amazing places but of course when you've
got a boyfriend or someone back home you
don't never get the chance to switch off
yourself or you know a lot of that those
guys that thrive in that environment or
girls or guys and girls that thrive in
that environment will then come back to
the UK and just sleep and wait for the
next next shift where as laws was coming
back trying to spend time with me
I was overworked overstressed and we
almost split up male oh it's genuine we
almost we got to a stage where our
relationship was really really bad we
decided to move in together it was a
great decision a few months later she
chief her pregnant but anyway I digress
slightly so that was a timing way in
which I soon learned that I'm done
like if I carry on this way I need to
all gasp my life a little better so I
don't I don't burn myself out what I
began to put in place that since then
it's just a greater level of
self-awareness than self-care a greater
level of ability to try and build up the
other side of my arch and and this
happens had this happened through it
through a mentor mine at the time who
was saying you know being a type-a
person as a person always looking for
that challenge like my whole days about
challenges because what I really know
what your being an athlete it's about
winning right so you know what that you
know challenges whether it's game day
you know what you know what how you need
to win in some of the metrics and the
scores so I'd look for that challenge
take that one off it's like yes dopamine
hit like I'm a beast net where's the
next challenge who wants it next type
thing but that again that would only
take you down you know one one one one
path and eventually that path is there's
going to be a dead end and you need to
reverse so yeah there's something they
said to me is about just trying to find
a bit more flow and that doesn't come
very easy to me it's a for me it was
about trying to find a hobby that was
outside of Fitness you know even things
like puzzles and chess as stupid as it
sounds I could net that those things
never write quite clicked with me but I
guess spending a little bit more time
and my son that was that that allowed me
to find flow going on
you look read in breda books I listen to
podcast and going going on walks and
being in nature and and just doing
things that weren't formal forms of
exercise which is all I knew about or
sitting behind a laptop and trying to
push business ideas I also will add to
that lot I do have a I seem to have a
large capacity for work and the boys are
very close to me at the gym you know
Alex our head coach he's always telling
me that he's like your brain just works
on this on this level of a capacity that
he can't keep up and sometimes I'll only
have my meetings I'll be like this this
isn't it and he sought ways as will come
from and I guess it's just my a bit of a
reactive nature a bit of a it's wanting
to just keep keep everything moving it I
guess it's engrained now in the culture
of March honest I just just keep going
keep moving right people around me you
know people around me rein me in when I
need to it when I need to be having that
support system it must be a big change
and as some
who independently has a similar mindset
to yourself always never never had a job
for anyone there wasn't me 18 years old
started running my own business very
quickly attached my sense of self
identity and self-worth to the success
of the business found it challenging to
detach that then went another step
further this second-order effect is
really pernicious and there may be some
entrepreneurs who haven't heard me talk
about this before that are listening if
you begin to attach your sense of
success to the amount of suffering
associated with the process of doing
work you have gone too far so I used to
have a successful club night 1,500
people really amazing door take accounts
look fantastic great reviews no problems
but if it come easy to me I'd feel
guilty and I'd go home feeling
unfulfilled because there was some part
of me that felt like suffering was
innate in success and that I needed to
suffer and it's a Puritan work ethic you
can imagine these priests doing hoeing
the gardens and self-flagellation in
service to God right it's a Puritan work
ethic and that's what I had I was
sacrificing myself in service to this
desire to be something but the problem
was I'd completely missed the bit that
mattered
I wasn't even chasing success anymore
and success should be in service to
happiness
so I'd bypass both success and happiness
and was just looking at further pain and
for the suffering and what it sounds
like you've done is begin to build some
structures in place forcing functions
that mean that you have to do the walk
the family time the hike the support
structure the second cousin's birthday
whatever it might be and when you then
reintegrate that with flow there's this
great quote from Kyle ashen Rhoda was
the the podcast I did the other day that
I know that you've listened to and he
talks about Confucius ancient
philosophies and Philosopher's talking
about how you first have to use the type
to thinking the slow and then it
integrates into the fast in the early
stages of training an aspiring Confucian
gentleman needs to memorize in Tai
shelves of archaic texts learn the
precise angle at which to bow and how
the lengths of steps are that he is to
enter a room with his sitting mat must
also almost be perfectly straight
all of this rigor and restraint however
is ultimately aimed at producing a
cultivated but nonetheless genuine form
of spontaneity indeed the process of
training is not considered complete
until the individual has passed
completely beyond the need for thought
or effort and that's what every training
plan is trying to achieve you're trying
to instantiate habits which you could
have naturally come upon we mentioned
this before you've happened upon some
good mindset tricks some new mindset
approaches that have then been reflected
in literature down the line and this is
the same thing again there will be
someone out there maybe someone who's
listening who happened upon the perfect
cadence of work rest family relaxed
entertainment perhaps myself and you and
a lot of the other people almost
everyone who's listening hasn't
therefore we got to work at it
but after you've done the work you can
actually then allow yourself to be more
free-flowing with it you understand your
limits more intuitively rather than kind
of academically that makes sense
completely complete sense yeah I think
you have to you have to live through it
to understand where I get understand
where in all of those things you're
trying to identify as that where the
priorities actually lie live through it
and then come up with your yo the best
version of the best iteration of it for
you and that then then might that might
change because priorities may change
other things might come in it goes back
to that a and B test and we sought
alluded to to earlier the things that
serve your life and that are working you
keep them in the things that aren't you
change them if you're dropping the ball
somewhere and B be willing to have those
difficult conversations with the people
that mean the most to you because that
constructive criticism from your wife
your best may your business partner your
employees that actually helps you be
better at the thing in which you're
trying to get better at if you're just
left your own devices meaning you're
quite similar personalities if you left
your own devices
you just yeah you're probably gonna get
it wrong you have to be willing willing
to take on the criticism and and
implement it and have those difficult
conversations that's the place that you
get the growth as well so some of the
things that I've noticed recently I was
on Makayla Peterson Jordan Pete's
install his podcast last week and her
YouTube channel has significant reach
which meant that there was a lot of
comments of people who were hearing me
for the first time and I was questioning
myself as I do I do I read these do I
read them yeah I'm going to and sure
enough went through and tons of people
have picked up on things that I've never
realized a bunch of vocal tics that I've
got some imprecisions in my speech some
pauses where there shouldn't be little
bits and pieces now most of these are
trolls online who are not doing this
from a virtuous standpoint and it was
painful for me to read some of that
stuff but I've not realized some of
these lessons in two hundred episodes
two and a half years of doing this
podcast probably three hundred four
hundred hours of recording content and
yet I had to have this uncomfortable
experience in order for me to be able to
deal with it another podcast I did with
Jason Calacanis Jay Kyle who's this huge
Silicon Valley investor he made it quite
uncomfortable he has got a very very big
following and made the podcast a little
bit not confrontational but it was at
least adversarial and I learned more in
that one episode than I've learned in 20
or 30 of the ones where it's just easy
and free-flowing yeah they're great but
I don't actually expand my competence
there and again this is why leaning into
discomfort as we spoke about earlier on
almost actively seeking that discomfort
even in the areas you don't want to feel
it so in an area of having a difficult
conversation yeah it's difficult why is
it difficult because it is outside of
your domain of competence but once you
do it that is now that box is ticked I
have that capacity I know that if I need
to approach my coach because he keeps on
turning up late and I know that it's
because he's got a young daughter or son
or whatever and it's going to be real
hard and it's all multifaceted and this
is
there's always a reason why my situation
is different when I have to have an
awkward conversation with someone that
works for me or a friend or whatever it
might be it's like no it's not it just
may be a little bit more nuanced go and
do the work
Gordon to the person have the difficult
conversation because it will make you
grow I think let's give you peace of
mind is personally like and we said
about the other reason those comments
and stuff and anyone that sort of going
to read negativity or want to take on
its criticism which is a good thing to
do so long as you can sleep easy at
night so long as everything you do comes
from one a place of good intention and
to like there's no lack of effort others
that there is definitely an incredible
amount of deliberate practice and and
the utmost of effort into everything
that you do and I think most people
there is so you can read those comments
and it's right I can read them and take
on the criticism and read them and have
an air of vulnerability if you die if
you're not willing to be vulnerable to
to to people that are gonna give you can
cut the constructive criticism or
challenge your belief system challenge
the way you do things then you're not
really in that way criticism is a gift
if you have a true growth mindset free
of ego any criticism a valid criticism
obviously like if it's just your hair's
[ __ ] it's like you're I don't like that
mustache it's like no this massage is
great if it's a legitimate criticism
your response should be thank you
because that is identifying a hole in
your game that you didn't know existed
and you've got it from this person for
free yeah maybe their intentions whether
I'm trying to [ __ ] you but I've [ __ ]
that and the mother like it's something
is something I've definitely definitely
like I said I'm not something's got it
all figured out and it ticks all the
boxes in everything that I'm trying to
be you know if I'm a coach right I'm a
coach I'm a business owner I coach
people and I also try and to some degree
coach my employees or the people that
work for the business or at least at
least communicate them into art with on
a level but the way in which I
communicate through my wife or my child
is very different the way in which I
need to communicate to the people that
come into my gym when I'm coaching is
very different to why I need to
communicate to my brother and sister who
work within with who work alongside me
and sometimes they'd be like look the
way you're speaking to me or the way the
way you've communicated that or where
you've gone about that's just not right
and when it's my brother and sister on
that the day you didn't put the cups in
the dishwasher and then the day before
there was this dirt over the far side
but but they're right like if if I if
I'm trying to be all of those things and
communication is we just pick on that as
it as a skill set and that's one of
those skill sets I need I need to take
it take it into consideration that if I
if I've quote-unquote employed my sister
or she's an employee of the company I
need to be able to separate the ability
to communicate with her as someone that
is looking after her job but then also
separate that from someone who's then
having to communicate with her as my
sister someone you know who is older
than me who's who's looked after me is
it as a kid and all the all these things
so there is it's just a constant
learning it's constant lying it's
constant willing to it to want to learn
there's levels to this game man and
talking to the older sister who you also
work with is probably up there with like
the hardest it's set Sarah right the SR
SR SR a shout out Sarah we were going to
go into training for ages man but I've
been loving this mindset stuff and I've
got more mindset stuff want to talk
about so I'm going to blast through a
little bit of training let's say the we
are back in the world of gym and that
something or that someone has access to
full kit
what are some of the workouts a couple
of workouts that you've written recently
that you've really enjoyed that you
think some people could go away and do
tomorrow so my training so just in terms
of my philosophy or style of training
now so people have seen this sort of
like train everything ready for anything
something and it again it's bought
bought bought out of strength
conditioning based principles and what I
used to do in the weight room that would
transfer on to rugby field to allow me
to in particular sevens to allow me to
be fast powerful strong adaptable water
super bust all the sort of things now
for me being a bit older and having to
wear those multiple hats that we've
alluded to it's training for me has to
have high bang bang for my buck needs to
leave me feeling fulfilled
it needs to be enjoyed I need to enjoy
it needs to be sustainable needs to be
repeatable I need to be able to train
and then go and wear one of those hats
that isn't the training hat whether it's
the coach the husband the businessman
etc so my training is very much
different now to how it has been over
the past I'll give you two I guess two
workouts that one one strength-based and
and one that might be even more aerobic
conditioning type things so for me when
we will meet when we talk about our
strength work of course we warm our
bodies up appropriately based on any
sort of conversations we've had in the
past injuries that sort of stuff so I'll
leave you guys you know to your own
devices with that we then put together
like a potentiation or movement prep
type block which will which will mirror
some of the exercises in which we're
going to go into in the in the Kishin in
the main strength area it might also
have some of the exercises in which
we're going to miss out because in that
session we just can't throw everything
into it so this talk session eggs are
about to go into so the key the KPI for
us the key performance indicators will
be a squat okay so we always build off
these these movement patterns so within
our movement prep we will do a variation
of the squat so it might be a goblet
squat high bang for our buck gonna
starts going to train the squat pattern
get our body aligned with what's coming
up we're gonna get some some good a good
amount of core bracing anterior cores
working nice and hard were going to
prime the body for what's to come
through there we then might put in a bit
more of a core dominant exercise so
again a hollow rock or a side plank cram
shell so again bang for our buck getting
some lateral natural core strength
stability there I'm also gonna get some
work through our glutes and we might put
an upper body exercise because then it's
a lower body bias session so let's let's
let's look at something like a press up
keep it nice and simple okay so we've
got ten press ups ten ten goblet squats
ten side plank and clamshells each side
we were then going to our squat that's
our main KPI and whatever we're building
through if we're going through a
training phase we'll build to a heavy
set of something so I quite like now
this this notion of sort of
autoregulation for my training a lot of
people this much similar to a like an
RPE scale given that unless you are an
athlete like I was when I was playing
rugby and everything was constructed so
that I should be able to hit a certain
percentage on a certain day unless I'd
had a tough on pitch session or I had a
bad
sleeeeep life is so dynamic that you
almost need to take physiology on a
24-hour clock like how are you feeling
on that day if you're supposed to hit a
certain number but you've slept really
bad you've had an argument with your
husband or wife you've not eaten
whatever you know the emails have blown
up in your face someone wants to you
know punch you you know that sort of
stuff just Auto regular basis on how
you're feeling so if today's it's five
reps we build to a heavy five all right
and we'll do that over for over five
sets again depending on time we might
pair that with an accessory exercise
something complimentary if you've got
issues around you know correctives you
could pair it with the corrective
exercise so let's just say we're finding
we've got really tight hips let's pair
our back squat with a like a count
stretch or you know just a static
stretch if we feel a little bit further
down our training journey with
intermediate advanced type type lifter
we might pair something with a
complementary pairing so might be an
upper body exercise we could go into a
dumbbell floor press as we've primed
with the press up it might be that we're
trying to really make that bias on a
lower body session so we might squat go
to the heavy five and we just pair that
with the kettlebell swing so twelve ten
to twelve swings so we're getting some
power into system as well so that'll be
our five sets that's our KPI again we're
moving to our accessory work if we're
taking this session as a lower-body
session we then look at a unilateral
pattern so maybe a split squat a lunge
step up something like that do you - you
always tend to have a bilateral with the
unilateral in there so for you again so
for someone like someone like me who
we're training volume is quite high
throughout the week and you know I'm
able to train five six days a week we
are I would I can go through like a
lower-body session and upper body
horizontal push-pull upper body vertical
push-pull then a more hinge dominant
session so I have the ability to stretch
my session out over a week and get my
volume in that that way for most people
when we're looking at bang for back if
we're going to if we're going to pair
the squat with the kettlebell swing we
can afford to go unilateral push-pull in
our accessory work so we're always put
in a fair amount of unilateral and
bilateral work so we might go like I
said split squat into a weighted push-up
into a three point dumbbell row four
sets of Channel knows and we always
finish with either some some pump work
so some metabolic like stress pump work
because it
that leaves us feeling good we're very
much aligned with trying to become
obviously become stronger I become
fitter but aesthetics is a big driver
for us it's a big driver for all humans
no matter what they tried to say even
people in the CrossFit world I still
believe there you know performance
driven you still want to look good so
long as we get the balance right with
that so we might finish with some upper
body pump work or we might finish with a
we might run build that into a
conditioning piece so some farmers
carries with a ski ERG with some with
some pull-ups and do five rounds of that
I hope that gives you enough to sort of
go with it in terms of how we structure
a strength session again we take into
each individual's you know training
volume throughout the week and then when
it comes to just capacity work fairly
simple if it's mono structural I've just
done one today which was which was 60
seconds on the salt bike 30 seconds rest
60 seconds on a skier 30 seconds rest
for 10 rounds so it's a 30 minute piece
20 minutes of work there's 10 minutes of
rest cumulative I gave myself some
targets so on the assault bike I was
aiming for 22 sorry on the on the scale
examined for 22 calories around
I was hitting around average probably 21
so always trying to set the bar over
higher just to make sure I push my
intense a little bit and then there's
assault by cars aiming for 20 calories I
think I hit 19 on average again I don't
try to push too much intensity when it
comes to my conditioning pieces these
days I'll probably push intensity once a
week but mostly it's just aerobic a bit
of headspace I like to work up a sweat
like that you know every way everyone
once more I feel good if it is though
you've got some work done fit as though
it's quite high output and fit as he
works up a sweat and then allows me to
go on with it whether over the rest of
my day you know coming on a podcast
having to speak and you know still got a
coach later on this evening so it fits
in that way hopefully that is that
giving you enough I love it man
absolutely great I like the idea of
using the RPE scale there's a number of
different
physios and world-class coaches have
been on this show talking about the
importance of using the equivalent of a
24-hour window as you said there if
you're if you've had a terrible night's
sleep in an argument with your boss and
just going to a punch-up outside in the
car park and all the rest of it
your today's
70% is tomorrow's 50% on you know you're
just not going to be working at your
best but tomorrow you might be so go in
see how you feel again what did we talk
about with that Confucian gentleman
thing you need to go in and have very
structured sessions this is the sort of
progression you are looking at and then
as you get towards that more
intermediate more advanced there is a
sense there is insight into your
training into how you feel I'll actually
I can piece all of these different
things together because previously I
wasn't considering about whether I'd
eaten enough over the last few days or
whether or not I'm feeling stressed at
work over the last few days I like that
it seems having had Ryan Fischer on this
podcast the the American ally March on
he has a lot of similar insights into
training as you do takes some of the
functional fitness potentiation zand
patterns but repurposes them into quite
fun and different new ways I think
that's that's the main thing I think a
mixed modality Fitness just allow you to
explore movement and different patterns
and energy systems and the way that and
it is so exciting and it keeps it keeps
things chat challenged and varied in it
in a more structured way I think for
most people sort of entering into it now
when we look at the Ryan fishes the
world and the markets Phillies and those
sort of those sort of people finally
enough I did a bit of research a couple
years ago into into when functional
bodybuilding started and when I launched
functional physiques and functional
physics came the forefront of
bodybuilding because again like I
started as a bodybuilder it started as a
bodybuilder because that's why I started
lifting weights at 14 we talked about
these early adopters like this this is
going back almost 1617 years there were
no 1415 year olds in the gym at this
time you know that's when I started
lifting started lifting weights so
bodybuilding was the thing you know it's
just like most people that start lifting
weights back then you follow the
magazine's you follow these people
when did you get your fitness menopause
when did you let go of the tether from
bodybuilding pulse rugby and go into
functional fitness
so I I went into functional fitness like
I said I started with with Saracens in
the Academy system from from from 15
years old weight started coming in at
like 16 17 like than 18 and playing
full-time full-time rugby so I was the
guy that because I was doing on pitch
conditioning games in the gym lifting
heavy weights my physique and the way I
looked look like the bodybuilder wanted
to look but only when he was ready to
die to compete on stage yeah and my
nutrition was always because again
earlier doctor I was into nutrition I
looked at the back then if it fits your
macros and following the you know the
people you know the the main norton's of
this world and all that stuff that was
first coming out and just being willing
to listen to all this that's all the
research so you know that see meals and
stuff that I'd eat be like how did you
eat that and look like that and just
just just wanted to understand it so
I've done rest a little bit with that
but my training I soon realized that by
trying to stay as strong as I could one
thing when I was playing 15s you know
there take our skin fold so trying to
maintain as much lean muscle mass as
possible and the ways in which you do
that that became quite important to me
from a young age again athletics
background I spend a lot of time down
the track and doing sprint base
conditioning that's very conducive with
with building a nice lean powerful
physique so all these things were
started fitting together and I started
painting this picture of my soul ok this
is that this is how I do it
dunking wrong this some sessions while
standing in front of a mirror and just
you know do bicep curls but I needed to
be I needed to be a good mover for that
for the rugby field you had you had a
very early fitness menopause man that's
that's that's one of the earliest
menopause is that I've heard of I think
I think I really did I really did and I
what I remember going to the first
couple of body powers and that sort
stuff and people used to say to me the
like geez when you compete you know when
you onstage I might do it I've never
competed I don't compete not my bag well
it's the same it's the same sort of
funny argument about a lot of CrossFit
the intensity appears to be one of the
key drivers of condition and that the
challenge that bodybuilders have is
keeping that intensity high it's not
unnatural
when you're steeping in your own
neuroses with your air pods in looking
at yourself in the mirror
it doesn't gas you up you can be
listening to the the heaviest death
metal or the brand-new H track or
whatever it might be but it doesn't gas
you up the same way as a room of 10
other people all throwing down at the
same time as you I actually think that
if there was a group bodybuilding class
like not not the Ryan Fischer march on
Marcus Philly stuff I mean like [ __ ]
Monday his chest and then it's just
chest but if you were to create
bodybuilding classes I reckon you'd make
some savage physiques out of that if you
were able to have the community aspect
the out sourced motivation aspect that
you get with CrossFit and with
functional training in classes and stuff
like that but it was just straight up 8
to 14 reps on contraction focused mirror
entire rooms mirror even the ceiling the
floors mirrored it's like a porn porn
set and I reckon I reckon you get some
absolutely beastly physique so other I
think that's just two fold here again
using the examples you've used the
Ryan's and Knoxville is this world one
even myself going back set foot that
foot there 14 years starting then what
we have is a considerable amount of
general physical preparedness right
we've done the bodybuilding beer we've
done multiple muscle contractions we've
tried everything there is to do we spent
you know days hours in the gym so it's
very hard for people to to to I guess
under they need they need to appreciate
that first and foremost when they when
they're entering into fitness we've only
been in two or three or four or five
years like spend some time building us
your physique and doing the hard yards
first and potentially specializing in
trying to gain some muscle for a period
of time before you start worrying about
[ __ ] I need to do the metcon or the
conditioning piece or going go on a run
like just build some muscle first and
foremost learn to move well first you
know your technique drill your technique
stick to the basics progressive overload
in everything in life is the way is the
way to go forward and that would be that
would be how it you know how you sort of
address that and then I think yeah when
it comes to then
further further down that training
journey you can be it you can afford to
be a little bit more generalized because
you've done the hard work and you've got
those muscular contractions and then
training just needs to be whatever you
[ __ ] enjoy doing whatever you can
enjoy and repeat repeatedly do day in
day out because if you just thrash
yourself and just push intensity you're
going to spend the rest of the day
probably with your feet up on the sofa
or you're not going to be able to train
the next day and you're gonna you're
going to burn yourself out and the last
point you alluded to with the
bodybuilding thing or people that people
are training and just not getting in
shape it's because you train with no
intensity and by that we don't mean you
know chase your anaerobic threshold
every you know every every every every
session and leave yourself dying on the
floor but it's like train with a bit of
intensity that's not just standing there
isolating certain muscle groups doing
body parts splits each day because if
you're doing that sort of thing in your
desk worker and you sit behind a desk
and you're going to be spending a long
time that's why bodybuilders blessum
have to spend hours on a elliptical or
cross trainer to cut weight into because
they train with no intensity and their
lifestyle outside the gym isn't
conducive we're just like moving and
trying to stay fit and healthy yeah
you're right man
you're right it's um it's gonna be
interesting to see where the sport of
Fitness's goes over the next few years
obviously we've had a very recent change
in CrossFit direction over the last year
and a half the cross for HQ pivoted a
lot more toward health than toward
performance I think that triggered an
awful lot of people in the CrossFit
community is it rightly so
I don't know CrossFit is a business a
training methodology and a sport and
trying to memory all of those things at
the same time is incredibly difficult
say what you want about Greg Glassman
and Dave Castro they had challenging
jobs trying to get CrossFit to be all
things to all people
you're telling me that you want a
training methodology that can get 60
year old seven year old Doris off the
couch and moving with no pain in their
hips and their knees but you also want
to create the fittest athlete on the
planet oh and actually it has to be a
profitable business model as well anyone
that thinks that they can do that easily
is an idiot III agree with you but also
what I will say on that is it's where I
think they fell short on it and this
isn't a bash at CrossFit just like our
previous conversation was not about a
body builders because to a large extent
I still am wondering have peen and on
and there are some great ones but
CrossFit then didn't apply or didn't
there are some great cost for coaches as
well as some great boxes I'm friends
with them as well being you know Benson
some great places they didn't the
memorial itself was a bit plug and play
no coaches really gained the knowledge
in which when when cross became about
the games and the map phrases you just
saw these crossed with boxes trying to
program like the games and what Matt
Fraser did rather than actually go back
to what CrossFit was designed to do
which was just meet the person where
they're currently at and their narrative
or the way in which they depicted this
18 months ago and start going down the
healthy route was just it was such it
was too far like again if I liken this
just to our gym our youngest members 14
our eldest members 72 we have multi we
have a number of people who are in their
60s who will squat who will do sled like
sled work who will do you know med bull
ground to over shoulder or variations of
because there is a regressions and
progression matrix to every movement
pattern there is so long as you and you
understand it and you know when to apply
it and that is the art of coaching and
programming which i think is where some
of the CrossFit stuff just got a little
bit muddled because the sexy Instagram
stuff is the map phrases and any others
top of cross for athletes they're doing
some gnarly [ __ ] but people ask me you
know what we do is just a watered down
version of what we coach is a watered
down version of what we do it's still
some of the same movement patterns same
exercises same bits of equipment but
it's meeting that person where it's at
what what Freight when I see Fraser do
workout I'll just do a very very very
very diluted like diluted version of it
because there's no point trying to
aspire to be like that because he's at
the very the very top of his game you
mentioned it earlier as well why would
you choose to do a workout which you
don't enjoy everybody that is listening
that is not a professional athlete does
not have to Train
you get to train the best training plan
that you can do is the one that you do
every day the best diet that you can do
is the one that you're compliant with
and that you stick to that means you
need to find the sport the physical
training methodology which is right for
you and sadly for you
it might not be CrossFit it might not be
functional fitness it might be Brazilian
jiu-jitsu it might be trampolining it
might be ultra marathons it might be
like Thai boxing it could be anyone of
every sport that exists on the planet
and all that you need to do is do
something that you enjoy yes if you
choose to do a sport which happens to
have some loading in it and some
progressive overload and some intensity
you may be able to get some more
socialized benefits in condition in the
way that you look and stuff like that
then you might be able to do if you get
in a French you go to the top flight of
French Bulls or something like that but
the point is that your compliance is the
key indicate the key driver of your
results so just do the thing that you
enjoy if you've spent all day grafting
away in the office doing all this stuff
and then you get into the gym to do an a
workout that you hate where no one has a
bottomless pit of willpower to dig into
and then you got to go home you're gonna
get the kids sorted all this sort of
stuff that allow your time in the gym to
be something that you indulge in and I
think the variety that you guys yourself
Ryan Marcus are bringing across I saw
Ryan today doing a landmine overhead
single arm lunge so you can imagine
you've got the barbell pivoted in the
floor in front of you far too much
weight on it and he's doing a siren look
at that movement I've never seen anyone
do it in the gym before but god I want
to do it I look it I'm like that looks
[ __ ] sick I bet that a single abs and
glutes at the same time about a single
arm landmine lunge is awesome I'm like
that's [ __ ] cool that is a cool new
movement yeah I think with it with it
all these moves I mean some and some
that come out or are a bit novel but I
guess the purpose here is with with
functional fitness and whatever that
term means to people the more you can
try and look globally and engage full
kinetic chain and get everything
working together again this bang for
your buck type thing so long as there is
rationale and justification behind while
you're doing it I think these exercises
are brilliant because you're going to
get like you're gonna get the so much
learning for the body there's this
stability there's balance this there's
the nationís there's strength is
coordination this is we're looking at
Contra lateral loading patterns and the
body the body's having to learn these
different things and it's just build yes
building like a more robust structure
just going back tracking a little bit
though what we said about just people
buying into whatever works for them
there are obviously some principles that
people need to adhere to and people are
always going to fall you know fall short
if and and mainly that for sure it comes
always that would lead back to strength
so it needs to be some sort of
underlying building of strength and
whatever that may look like for you but
once you understand the principles and
nutrition and training and progressive
overload then whatever method you choose
is just something that you're gonna
you're going to enjoy and what yeah for
most people that's going to be what is
the lowest barrier lowest hanging fruit
to begin with both financially time
commitment and effort no to begin with
and that that's absolutely fine because
you need to start slow and then as your
training journey improves and you want
to put more skin in the game and invest
more into it both time finances finances
etc then you take the next step and that
is the beauty that's why I'm so that's
why I don't even look back at my rugby
career anything I wish I still played
rugby because training is so pure like
there is there is always an opportunity
to get better and learn and and you know
that exercise for example you Ryan like
I've done variations of you know but but
not that but this is an exercise that
you can go you can go and actually try
and try something and see where how you
fare with it and you can then progress
that exercise and maybe then you can
move from the from the landline press to
you know the dumbbell press and then you
can look at some other piece of
equipment with it it's such a it's an
amazing thing to be a part of it's a
cool man preparing the human body and
the savages that you've got in your gym
and all the gym owners that are
listening as well what lesson do you
wish ollie from five years ago knew
lesson that you know now or what lessons
that you know know if you could send a
couple of notes back is there anything
that comes to mind okay so I think one
of my the biggest struggles I've had of
recent times is trying to keep everyone
happy and I think as a coach and as
someone that does try and help their
neighbor a lot like I would give the
person next to me my t-shirt and not
just want to be taught the style time
but I would generally do that it's you
know in recent times like you cut you
just can't keep everyone happy and
ultimately if you try and keep everyone
happy the person that's not going to be
happy as yourself now I know that's that
might be quite deep but how did that how
did that manifest with the Cova thing
mate with that with the Cova thing what
I realize is and you know a few people
that are further down the track farther
down the track to me far bigger
businesses and good mentors of mine and
I'm very fortunate I have a lot of good
people around me though that have helped
me along the way right and just stumble
across any of this stuff when when the
gym needs to be closed I mean something
like our gym we're very lucky that our
gym is is we've got to that stage in
business I listened to one of your
podcasts I forget who it was and they
were talking about the business
hierarchy right and when you know first
thing the sellers profit order and then
we get to stage where it's almost like
this this this long is bigger impact
more impactful yeah well I think legacy
was the lark was the last state fought
to stage fire but whatever this stays
for was it's about like more than that
time in which they spend within your gym
so my gym it you know particularly
personal trainers as well this isn't
just exclusive to my business but you'll
hear a lot about that gym changed my
life well that person changed my life
because it might be a drastic weight
loss it might be that they suddenly get
found more attractive by their partner
or their sex life has improved or their
confidence has improved or their mental
clarity and and and and just energy to
be able to play with their kids is
improved and has changed their life
right so when something like that
happens for these people and they're
also got a financial commitment with it
with a gym and the gym it also got a
friendship sock within the gym and the
gym providers this route is part of
their routine in this community and
all those things and then it suddenly
closes it's like what it was for me like
you your whole life just gets turned
upside down and then you've got all
these people that not all of them say
that for the same reasons are upset
about some are about something not only
because there's a killer virus on the
loose and that their job security is
gone and they're in lockdown and they're
you know and they're now homeschooling
but the gyms also closed and that was
the x y&z to them and I just found
myself like having to feel all these
conversations and and trying to keep
trying to appease everyone and I think
the bigger your circle gets and the
people that you serve the harder it
becomes to just cry and keep everyone
happy and it's not for like lack of
trying and I would always try but it
just gets to stage where just like I'd
go to bed at night in my my stress
anxiety and depressive thoughts begin to
creep in so I think that answers your
question in terms like what I teach
myself is that when you when you're
trying to grow a business particularly
in the service industry or wherever
where you have customers
you cannot keep even with the best
customer service and the best intentions
you can't keep everyone happy and the
other thing I would say is just have
better conversations so if things are
weighing on your mind or if it's a
member of staff or one of your members
or a family member that's just have a
conversation because I like again a lot
of the a lot of the things I've
experienced over the last three four or
five years when it comes to my
relationship with my wife my
relationship with my brother who's also
my business partner my relationship with
some of the members just get on the
phone and just talk it out because no
one's trying to come eat that no one's
coming each other from that from that
from our own place
it's probably just a lack of
communication or a misinterpretation or
just trying to find out with that
person's act because it might be they're
just taking something out on you that
it's really nothing to do with you and I
love the idea of having a conversation
as quickly as possible the concept from
David Allen's getting things done called
the next action and his solution to any
to-do list item is as something appears
in consciousness I think what is the
next physical action that I can do so to
response there's an equivalent in
stoicism the dichotomy of control when
something happens is this within my
controller was is it without with my
control
an equivalent here that you could almost
apply why when you have an interpersonal
challenge with someone that your
response is to bring it up as soon as
possible that is appropriate one of the
main reasons for this I've been
ruminating about recently is there's an
opportunity cost to not doing it every
minute that you spend thinking about
that situation is a minute that you
could have saved by just having it done
the conversation get it out of the way
yeah it's bad but it's no less bad in
four weeks time you've just wasted four
weeks of your life thinking about it
condoms and I mean everything that in
action is a killer like inaction is a
killer and what happens is things just
manifest themselves and we talk about to
do this and productivity and trying to
get things done this you're just adding
more and more site to this to-do list
which at some stage you need to address
the problem
just like inbox it just get it done like
you have to have the difficult
conversations hopefully someone that's
listening might be inspired by that if
you are thinking I've got this thing
I've been putting off for ages I need to
speak to my dad about the way he spoke
to me last week or I need to speak to my
my boyfriend about why he keeps on doing
that just have the conversation with
them sit down
be truthful be honest don't be
passive-aggressive don't be overly
aggressive show your vulnerability be
truthful with it and so look this is how
it made me feel what can we do how can
we work together to get past this you
know it that is the route to raising up
everyone around you Matt and that just
at last got on that and we said working
with people I think that collaborative
effects like collaboration with people
is so powerful if you can if you can
collaborate and like I said meet people
where they're at work and be willing to
listen and also then guide that
collaborative thing and in any walk of
life is its power effort is one of the
few things that doesn't divide when you
share it it multiplies mm-hmm yeah what
area of self development do you want to
improve on most of the coming year
ah parenting I've got another child on
the way coming in September and my wife
is honestly anyone that knows Lauren she
is like 1 in that trillion
I guess because she's been with me for
so long she's been through the highs and
the lows and just understands me well
not when I talk to some my best mates
and friends who have amazing girlfriends
and fiance's and partners and stuff like
law's just she just gets it she doesn't
give me any stress and world world-class
wife and she's yeah she's like wife she
really is but why I do understand is
that we're coming out of Kovac hopefully
sometime soon we need to build back a
vast vast chunk of our business that's
been lost like it you know its impact
does it has everyone else and I have
another child coming along that's going
to you know being around the same time
so those those hats in which I wear and
those people that identify as I'm gonna
need to do some work on those and it's
she is so good with our son Leo but of
course she's gonna be you know her
abilities are gonna be stretched so
that's something I really to work on
Leo's getting set to age now where he's
actually beginning to warm to me as his
father figure ittle bit more you know
and and and I wit now is a really crunch
time for me to build that relationship
with him I think for the first 18 months
as much as I know I I do believe I'm I'm
a good father I've not been probably
been as good as I could be if I if I'm
really self-critical and now that he's
coming to her own age and now where he's
gonna need me more and also Lauren's
been even more and a new baby will he be
more I need to make sure that I get get
that right so that that's where I'm
gonna develop myself that's awesome man
have you got any plans to read stuff are
you considering taking courses or is
this just to be as present as possible
use the self-reflection and iterate on
what works yeah that's always sort of
that's always what we've worked for me
and also I think again just a more
collaborative effort with Lauren and and
I think look I know what I know where I
fall sure I know that I'm the sort of
person when I get home and it's time to
switch off and I get an email at 7:30 8
o clock at night I try and answer it if
I get if I wake up in the middle of 9
it's you know and it's midnight and I'm
and I stupidly I know you've always told
me keep my phone at my room but if I if
I if I know that something needs doing
that isn't gonna affect anything but I
just it way on my mind I'll try it I'll
try and do it so like you know you've
got no phone Sunday I think you did you
do it no no phone Sunday's there's
things like that I need to be look if I
want to get home whatever time it may be
on these certain days just just get out
like I mean last night I spent 20
minutes on the floor in my bedroom with
Leo diving off the bed onto me for 20
minutes he just jumped up one side the
double bed run across it and dive on me
and it honestly was so fulfilling and
when I normally again like I sit a sit
downstairs and I'm trying to decompress
and I'm I'm eating and I'm doing some
shite on my phone trying to you know
filter through social media post the
conversations that I haven't got back to
and I can hear Lauren and Leo like
conversating in like baby language and
her her talking and there's like giggles
and fun and all this stuff and I'm like
[ __ ] I should be over there man and so
it's a it's a it's an effort oh now I've
put it out there I'm gonna hold myself
accountable that it's just you know and
again make it easy start slow I'll go
and do two nights you know I can't go
and get involved with time a little bit
more and then and then progressively
overload myself into it because yeah we
need to you know do you have a bit of
self-care don't try and throw yourself
in the deep end cuz you sit yourself up
a failure
recursive Oh progressive overload is
king in all areas of life that is the
takeaway from today
- fantastic podcasts that you should go
and listen to if you are a young father
or mother who is thinking how can I make
more time for my family first off is my
conversation with Greg McHugh and the
author of essentialism he has his family
is the most important thing in his life
by a factor of 10 to everything else and
this guy's in New York Times bestselling
author so if his book is by a factor of
10 less important than his family you
begin to get an idea of how highly he
holds his family and I would suggest
listening to chasing excellence with Ben
Bergeron I think he has a fantastic
structure for the way that he pieces his
daytime work running CrossFit viewing or
CF any now as CF North New England and
his family life together he has some
hard lines that you can implement into
your life as well some stuff like 5 p.m.
every day he
leaves the jimmies out of the doorman he
has a meeting with a client or whatever
he'll pack his bag at 4:59 and be saying
right yeah that's great that's great and
then he's out the door and he's away
because that's what Ben does he leaves
his phone in a box and blah blah blah
it's tons of different things but as
always mentioned here start by being
deliberate with your practice you don't
just get good at lifting weights or
doing a squat you have to learn about
hinging at the hips and bending at the
knees then keeping your chest up then
tightening in on the bar but after a
while it will become to begin to flow
but you have to put the work in you need
to learn and especially when we have
these things that don't necessarily have
an instructor you know there's no
there's no one coaching you through
being a parent at the moment it's just
this intuitive daily game where you can
get caught up so set yourself some
bright lines see how they work and then
reflect on it without judgment not
everyone is going to be a perfect parent
or a perfect athlete or a perfect coach
or a perfect businessman or a perfect
husband or wife or whatever it might be
but you can be a bit less [ __ ] than you
were yesterday and I think if you
continue to try and iterate on that
you're going to end up in a good place
there are two things on that scrum Greg
McEwen right essentialism listen to the
podcast I actually bought the book off
the back of it to give to it gives one
of my friends and there was something
really wrong true what he said there
whenever he goes on a business trip he
takes one of his kids with him yeah just
interesting it's incredible and it's
like you know what why not take the
business trip on your terms with with
your closest confidant ie your offspring
and take them with you and what a
relationship that you can think and have
as a father I really really enjoyed that
pop that podcast it took a lot from it
and then just that second but you said
there about I mean for me that last
night that example which was real
positive import reinforcement it's like
I've gone upstairs wasn't what I'd
normally do at the time which I normally
do it and I had twenty minutes of just
uninterrupted amazing time with my son
like that that would only be like
compound interest go up there again
today do the same thing go to bed so
fulfilled and what a perfect finish to
the finish and so yeah well we're all
alone I love it man look Ally man we
made it we made it the internet asked
for it and you [ __ ] delivered mate so
where should people go they want to find
out more about you what you do the gym
what you want to leave them with
so yeah if you follow me on instagram
it's just a tony marcin our services a
german ww-watch incarnate UK so
programming if you just want to reach
out we do new training nutrition if you
just want to come and have a chat
just follow me on instagram slide into
my DMS i do try and get back to people
that that approach it with you know the
right a bit of effort and what they're
trying to communicate across to me yeah
other than that I promise Chris like
I've been waiting to come on this
podcast or we've been waiting sets up
foot for a long time now I've been
deflecting other podcasts and stuff
because I this was this was it for me I
think the only thing better than doing
this is Joe Rogan Chris that's and then
I thought the next for you man Chris is
them
Chris has helped me with a little bit of
sale for my own my own podcast so in
time again it for me the podcast is just
an opportunity to bring some of the
people which I've set the table with and
had good conversations with and bring
that to the people that follow me
interested me and hopefully at some
stage I'll be able to UM tempt you with
it abates come on that repay the favor
I am ready if you can get Chad sat
opposite me with his mustache in this
mess we can all wear up we can all wear
our blue blockers and you can get the
brownies in I think that's what a way to
spend an afternoon is that going to be
the march on podcast or something
similar
yeah I've toyed with names and stuff we
saw there going to be something yes
something around the March on podcast or
this anyt mentality but we'll see cool
well if that is out before this episode
goes up it will be linked in the show
notes below if not just follow Ali on
Instagram we put some fantastic content
great workouts and a pretty good rig and
a great tan as well so that's all man
the Internet's going to ask for this
again so you probably get a better right
get a better get ready for round two
yeah perfect I look forward to mate
thanks for having me on
[Music]